[موسيقى]
هذا هو متحف الصور الشخصية الوحيد في
الشرق الأوسط وهذا هو
أكبر متحف سيلفي
في العالم من حيث عدد الفنون في
الواقع افتتحناه في عام 2019 في ديسمبر
واستغرق الأمر ما يقرب من عام
ونصف لنصنعه
نحن  في مجال السياحة بالفعل
وهذا ما كنا نفعله على مدار 15
عامًا الماضية ، لذلك أردنا أن نفتح شيئًا جديدًا
مختلفًا مثل كيف تبدو دبي
وكأنك تعرف شيئًا فريدًا
وكانت هذه هي فكرة تقديم
شيء فريد في هذا المكان إلى دبي
وهو الوحيد
الذي يختلف تمامًا عن متاحف السيلفي الأخرى
لأن الفن الذي
استخدمناه مختلف لأن معظم
متاحف السيلفي عادةً ما تكرر
معظم فنها ولكن لدينا كل شيء
مختلف تمامًا عن المتاحف الأخرى
لكل لوحة وكل لوحة
الفن في شكل ثلاثي الأبعاد ، لذلك عندما تلتقط
صورة ، تصبح جزءًا منها
، وهذه هي الطريقة التي تصنع بها الذكريات
وهناك شيء لكل شخص تعرفه
لأنه إذا كان لديك  180 آه ،
من الواضح أنه يوجد
شيء للجميع هنا
جمهورنا هو بشكل أساسي من السياح ومن
الواضح أن الناس من دبي ولكن الأطفال
أيضًا ، لذلك عادة ما نحب
الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يأتون إلى هنا مثل ثلاثة
أجيال وهم جميعًا عائلات
ويأتون جميعًا  هنا لذا فهو جيد للجميع
[موسيقى]
أنت